tu pars mentir on arrive aux cinq
dernières minutes et avec notre invité
cet invité ses commandes et bryce de
nice on dit ce qu'on veut qu'on dise que
funny or die by the night price alias
jean dujardin les assauts loulou le
cumulard mais c'est touche à sa fin ça
fait beaucoup
alors j'ai plein de questions d'ailleurs
à l'oreillette on me disait mais comme
on dit on dit ça farte c'est ça on dit
ça face à la récession 10h alors c'est
bien ça c'est le ça farte oui je sais
venue sur un put de sa glissade vient du
dictionnaire voilà j'ai trouvé sa forme
de soutien ça serait pas mal à voir
qu'il y en avoir aussi son bonjour qu'il
est son bonjour à lui donc voilà ça y
est vous l'avez cherché voulait
travailler quand on écrit un sketch on
cherche des mots comme ça a dit tiens
farter farter sa force tient ça tape ça
me plaît je prends ces voix là ça j'ai
répondu la question qu'on me pose est
est-ce que vous avez vous rendez compte
que vous êtes en train de devenir comme
on dit dans la presse un véritable
phénomène de société ou l'a carrément vu
lui oui dont je dirais un modèle un
exemple obliger à être être très
prétentieux non je peux pas dire ça
c'est je suis ravi de ce qui se passe
évidemment mais maintenant phénomène
c'est le blond qui surtout qu'avec qui
marchent pas c'est le surfeur qui marche
mon camp je suis protégé par salon ça le
blond le surfeur et son maillot étriqué
sombre en short on va le voir tout de
suite dans ce petit extrait de brice de
nice on regarde
le patron de mer c'est pour qui pour toi
c'est pour 4 personnes n'ont pas bougé
la mer la fin je n'étais pas là elle a
fabriqué la mer kevin c'est ce qu'on va
faire je regarde ma mère si elle du ciel
tu m'appelles ok
elle est d'accord
ap bryce c'est gratuit c'est bon et
comment on dit parce qu'il y avait le
hockey lah de visiteurs vous c'est le
cas c'est cassé oui c'est ça le prend
tout en haut il faut le finir c'est en
bas ça c'est ça sa part dit dans l'ouest
pour exaucer dans les récrés seul moyen
des jeux qu'ils aient cassé je sais pas
pourquoi maintenant j'ai compris en
voyant le film y avait travolta aussi
mais maintenant il ya effectivement il y
avait ça aussi c'est ça a été travaillé
ça a été travaillée au départ le cas
c'était plus timides et puis c'est vrai
je les jeux léa mort c'est comme ça et
je me suis c'est plus absurde enfin
voila je voulais rester sur le cac c'est
alors on vous connaît nous on vous a pas
découvert là dedans vous à découvrir
d'abord sur france 2 avec un gars une
fille non et en fait pendant que vous
faisiez un gars une fille brice de nice
de niles vannes personnage continuer de
vivre ce que vous l'aviez créé avant
absolument
moi j'ai raccroché avec brice de nice je
faisais des petits modules avec ce
personnage en 99 avec les amis les nous
c nous et puis effectivement j'avais
lâché donc la perruche me suis dit j'en
tire le personnage je passe à autre
chose et c'est vrai qu'il a continué à
vivre grâce à notamment alexandre pietra
et rebbie lanvin qui ont créé un site
sur brice et voilà c'est grâce à eux
aussi pendant cinq ans sur acer nairay
absolument que vous faites on continue à
s'échanger des watchmen et qu'on
m'appelait brice je m'appelle brice
encore dans la rue c'était très très
étonnant mais effectivement c'est à la
force du net a priori moi je suis ni
surfer dans la vie ni surfer sur le net
donc je me rendais pas vraiment compte
d'où ils venaient d'ailleurs ce surfeur
il vient il vient y vient de ma tête
il vient d'en il ya six rencontres et
des bri en terminale qui était comme ça
un personnage créé par an de recul qui
est assez intéressant qui se moquaient
tout le monde et puis je les fais
connecter avec les surfeurs de la côte
atlantique je me suis ça pourrait faire
un personnage intéressant pour le pour
le café théâtre voilà donc c'est un
mélange de plein de personnes est ce que
ce tumour vous reconnaissez dans les
jackass dans l'est
michaël youn dont ces gens là ou non a
priori non non je j'ai juste j'ai juste
je suis mon instinct je me suis dit il
faut que je forge même plus où je
retrouve la même fraîcheur que j'avais
sur scène ou à la télé je me suis dit
faut vraiment que ma muse avait un père
un peu vide à personnage de composition
un personnage entier absurde il faut les
genoux est un peu con aujourd'hui
quelqu'un je vais pas me les coûts il
est plutôt décalé différent et je dirai
pas combien s'il vous plaît enfin je
pense que non non c'est non pas d'un an
il est pas con il est juste décalé c'est
un personnage qui est vraiment décalé
qui est en quête en circuit fermé dans
sa bulle jaune
le monde autour ne l'est pas lui en tout
cas les voilà il n'aspire qu'à une chose
c'est ça casse la baraque vous avez
dépassé les 1 million de millions
d'entre eux les vannes en est d'accord
et puis il y aura un pareil soonnight ou
deux peut-être à la neige il fallait là
il fera de la loge et il fera aussi
sûrement merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être venu voilà on arrive à la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi tout
de suite la météo c'est nathalie